nina dobrev will return to the Vampire  Diaries  there's no flying to me get excited  after months of speculation the actress  confirmed the news on Instagram Thursday  with a pic of her scrip captioned  I know it's Thursday but this is not a  TV T hashtag back on set thanks to Nina  we know the title of the CW shows finale  is I was feeling epic Nina played Elena  Gilbert on the hit drama for six seasons  before leaving I felt like it was time  for a change to debut a new me recently  28 year old Nina has also sparked  romance rumors with Glen Powell I sees  I'm Rui but a source tells ET the two  actors are just friends another source  says quote Nina and Glen are not dating  [Music]